hello to all thank you for being here and
welcome to the cloud suite
my name is lucie and i am only steam
from google cloud customer a
junior that means that i will make the
link between the customers or their until
their needs and  our solutions among our
solutions on google cloud some
of them are powered by
artificial intelligence and
machine learning and that's what we
're going to talk about today
today i'm also going to be
accompanied by simon who  is that of a
lead engineer at devoteam to our
partners as well as yoann folle data
scientist at solvay and avs and have
acquired and responsible for big data and
analytics at solvay also before
starting we will all try together to
answer a small  question what is
machine learning globally at a
high
level machine learning is a mechanism that
will teach computers to
recognize patterns in the same
way as it would our brains  without
machine learning
we will try to define rules and
in almost all cases we are
sure to always find a
counter-example to these rules
something that will come quickly is shattered his
dreams suddenly instead of wanting to write
rules we're going to try to write
code code that will come and find these
rules for us and that's machine
learning and intelligence and
automatic learning
excuse me for being a little more
concrete we're going to start with a
example that a very original example which the
distinction of a cat and a dog
globally we will have an image and we
will suddenly build a
neural network to identify the result of
this categorization so it is a cat
or c  is a dog for that we will take
as input all the pixels on an image
and then we will review our relatives our
layers of neurons point that the
intermediate layers
globally these layers of neurons will
have a functioning  close to on
our brain with a neuron being an
attribute that we will
look for and that will help us
in the classification in the search
for results to do that we will
add weightings to its
neurons weightings that  will be
initially fixed randomly so
given results that will not be
consistent and
as training and examples
and experience progress we will come and adjust our
federations now before
starting with machine learning we
will do it together  a little exercise that
will be an exercise
we will seek to manually identify
the content of an image without
automated learning suddenly once
again a very original example therefore
the distinction of an apple and an
orange only a basic case  for
us it seems obvious to us now we will
seek together to define rules
what could be the criteria for
distinguishing between an apple and a
glo orange  what stands out the most is going to
be the color so the color
works
if tomorrow we have an image that is a little
different so a color that will
vary
or a black and white image
as if the rule no longer works so you
have to adjust  the rule or else create a
new rule we will for example want to
add the shape or the
texture again now we will
look for added a fruit so a fruit
case neither the same color nor the same shape
nor the same texture well
we have to define  to define rules
and rework it so you're going to
tell me we took examples that are
quite similar in the fruits there
are quite a few that are quite similar
and yes it's true so we could
come and ask ourselves the question and if we stay  that it
would not be easier between two
elements which are completely distinct
such as for example a dog is a
stone but in reality it is not
always the case
and precisely when we do something
without learning  automated and by
defining the rules ourselves
that means that we have to be
aware of all the cases of all the
nuances is stupid and that in mind before you
even see them appear
well I don't want to discourage you either
but still  once
there we did fairly simple categorization cases
so at b abc now if
we wanted to come and model
everyone around us is
clearly low we need machine
learning and automated learning
and once again  there
we only did images
if now we want to come and
process other types of unstructured data
such as video
audio text
you know the chorus finally
no worries we have solutions
so globally on the part  left
is what we talked about in the previous session
we provide you with tools that
are do it yourself make your
own model with your own data
now on the right part we give you the
di  sposition of the models which have
already been entered but overall we
hear more and more about machine learning
and to make machine learning one of the
prerequisites and to have data it
seems obvious and we for our internal needs
we have started to make models at
google and we had a lot of data and
it is these models that we are making available to you
today in the form of an api
globally through its five as countries
that are on the screen we are
making models available to you that  are
trained which are ready to use and
with a use which is simple and
fast
we will immediately move on to the
presentation of the different APIs and
before that I will explain to you a little
how we will work today
overall I will  present the
functionalities of the APIs and then as
we are aware that the distinction of a
cat or a dog is not necessarily a
new skies profession that speaks to everyone
we will also have concrete use cases
q  ui have been set up with
our customers which will be developed
by devoteam and its
lifting suddenly we will start with the first
to country the first a country this speech and
looting speech eyepea it you
already know it for most of
you  maybe under a slightly
different keyword through your phone or
google through google hockey
okay I think I heard the beeps
I may have triggered assistants
in the room
overall this pitch he stopped speech
eyed peas and provide your
developers through an api the possibility of having
this functionality of speech to text
as you already know I wanted to
insist today on the simplicity
of use
we have an api which can only be used  in
api rest standard which is also
usable from
client libraries in most popular languages
l find for example the pit w
know the java legault notes it ru
by the toll does and I'll go on th
re on  this example is an example in
python you see that I bring the
client library
so I do the configuration I send
my audio file and I write in coding
at the configuration level and I
just called after my api  to get
the result
this api it supports more than 110
languages it has a lot of features inclu
ing background noise reduction it wo
ks in buffered stream and we al
o released a new featu
e a few weeks ago which
is the introduction of times  stamp
overall i want to send a
harman api audio file and i will get in
reply the transcript of this
audio file which is at the very top and in addition to
transcription i will now have
all the evils which are dense 34 years old
script sorry with the date of  start
and end date so we're going to go to
a little demo or overall I'm going to
have videos and I'm going to
extract the audio part that I'm going to
send a speech eyed peas before
you  we will show it
we are going to explain a little bit the
architecture that has been put in place we
have dissociated the backend from the front ten
globally on the backend we have
input videos that we are going to add
to a file storage
system this system of  file storage we
connect it to functions its functions
they listen to certain
events the event in question is
an addition of a new file to the
storage system so
I add a video to my
storage system my  function will trigger the
function what will do the
function will extract the audio part
they sent a speech alpilles a
speech ajkai it will send back the result
that I will store again in a
storage system
I render all of this so  visual on
a front ten which is hosted on hardly
jean that we will immediately go and
watch
so here I am on my interface
which is hosted on hardly jean where you can
see that I have a lot of videos
overall i can click so on
any video i
was sure it would do it to me i think
this is a fairly common problem that
they found wifi who learned and
that's ok so that's ok this time
it's ok  so I get my video
below I see the whole transcript so
what is the first part that sends me back to
my speech at epinal below on this
transcript I can now come and
click on any word is
skilfully led directly to the moment
in the  video where there's making fun appears
good what's the point it's also used to
suddenly do research on
audio or video type content
depending on what is said in the video
for example now I can come and
do a search on  platform and
regardless of the title regardless of the
tags I would have put on it I will
find all the videos that
contain the word platform so here is
this api it can be used in a
country through the command lines as
we see it  have seen you can also
now come back to test it on your
browser from the url cloud point google.com
slash speech before even starting
any development
we will immediately go to the apei of
natural language processing
once  that we extracted from the text we
may want to do an analysis on
this text
and that's what we're going to do naturally
in Guadeloupe there's one of the first
functionalities we have in nature and
the ajkai language is fine  to
be extracting entities globally here
i have a text that talks about jk rowling
who is the author of the harry potter saga
i will send that naturally to
yahoo widgets which will detect me
different entities in this sentence
on each of these  entities I'm going to have
a piece of gisin that will describe this entity to me
for example I don't roll in it has just
detected that it's a persons type entity
and will also send the link
to the wikipedia page corresponding to
john rollins on british
eelv has been detected that this is a
location and it will send you the
link to the great britain wikipedia
page again harry potter will
detect this is art and will send to the
harry potter page so i  I'm not going to do
that for all the entities that we
extracted
but overall we have that for all the
entities that are in this text we
also have a sentiment analysis so
we see a sentence of it in this api and had
then turned two things to  valves or
return the score ranging from -1 to 1 - 1
being negative 1 being positive and the
magnitude the magnitude varies between 0 and
100 overall settlement the magnitude 6
with the force the longer I will have a
text the more I will have
a  magnitude which is important
in this example on Thursday the dishes were
awful I wouldn't go back there
mans it's not very positive and the sme
suddenly returns minus 0.9 for the
sentiment score I'm also going to have a
syntactic analysis so I'm going  s providing
a sentence in support here natural
languages chirp helps us to under
tand the text and I'm going to have
whole bunch of elements as a result so I'm goi
ng to see the dependence between the words I'm g
ing to see it the role of the word in the
sentence I'm going to have the type of words
is it a down is an adjective an
adverb of a verb I'm going to have the
roots of the word roots being the
singular of a plural or being
the infinitive of  a verb and I'm going to
have morphology
so that that you don't necessarily have to
correct the grammar of children that
that will help us understand
what our clients do to make an
interpretation from the text know
who the subjects are  what is the action
and what I and what
can I do in response to that we also
released new
features earlier we saw the
entity extractions after we saw
the  sentiment analysis now we
released the sentiment analysis on these
example entities on Thursday
I liked the sushi but the service
was horrible it will detect me
several entities in particular in sushi and
services and will be able to
hate me only on sushi I have a
feeling which is positive with a score
of 0.9 and that on  service I have a
feeling that is negative with a score
of -0 9 latest new
features that we released supernatural
language ndiaye it's the
overall classification I give a text as input
and I'll have in return that they
talk about  baseball and I'm going to have
in return
this text talks about baseball which
belongs to aspord team which belongs
to sport and tomorrow it allows you to
make on your text type elements a
classification which will be displayed
suddenly we will immediately go to the  demo
the demo globally we launched a script
which is a bear which runs on a machine
which will listen to twitter on the tweets
containing the word paris
these tweets we collect them we send them
to natural language and pia and we
store them  e in packages so yes
[ __ ] I think you've already
heard about it during the day
it's a multi from tallec that will
allow us to do both the
storage part and the analytics part in
that  she's years old up to petabytes and
having very good performance features
on the analysis part if you're
interested I invite you to stay at the
next session which talks about becaud and
so here is the table that I have
the table with the  tweets date of
creation the number of followers who
had known that a tweet and the
potential hashtags are below and after all
a large all a large text jason which
corresponds to the response of my natural
language hyypia i'm just going to
show you how much i  of occurrence I
just want to go make embossed on the
table to show you how many
rows I have in this table
no
good I'm going to pass in the fall but
because there I have the impression that I have
a small  problem on this co and who
n  normally takes yes in fact I have my
page that is no longer responding so I'm going
to show you directly the other kate
the other 4 so it's a query
overall the result is that
I had ten thousand ten thousand tweets in
madam at the table the other kate it's a
query that will combine sql is
something called user du fign
sanctions that will be
javascript functions that I can include let's sleep
sql directly and globally what I
'm going to do it  is that i will count the
number of goals and the occurrence of
the adjective the adjective how i
get them i get it from a
father on on the design whoever and in
madam so i will spin this
but i  hope it will work
because this one is clearly in the
process of it's always like that
anyway it's the effect of words and it was
necessary at least one demo which crashes
during the day so I devote myself for
my  colleagues a basset the sky
operate so globally there c  what we
see is that suri tweet de paris the
adjectives that look the most it's
French new good big little I want
an analysis on it I don't think there's
anything very interesting
but but I tell you  leave it free and
the other the other little thing that we
could do was what are
the most tweeted emoji by counting
once again their number
of occurrences and making it an
emoji extraction alas this time
what we see is that for
Parisians, at least those who
talk about paris, the most
tweeted emoji are the little smiley who
laughs bigger and the little
smiley who cries walid
here are little ips to look like
movie on
twitter suddenly once again this api so
api rest client library is
directly from your
browser from slash natural language this
time is now I will
immediately invite simon from devoteam to
present you a concrete use case  that  'we have
set up with our customers
[Applause]
thank you thank you also for this
presentation
so a concrete and direct case of the
technologies that we have seen is for me
the support center and in the
support center we will talk about the  call center
so you're going to tell me it's not very
original, we saw it before accession
yes, but it's no coincidence because
in the call center we have a
problem which is obvious
there are a lot of  data but the deal
and it's voice and the voice it's
unstructured and what's
the problem with a given of the
structures and it's that it's
difficult to use so it's
done today  today in a call center we
have an operator who comes to take
notes on a conversation there are
transcriptions made but it is not
systematic at devoteam
we have implemented a packaged solution
that uses google technologies
to respond to this problem  so
we use speech and  as soon as the
uci has shown you how to transform the voice
into text
then we use the country of
natural language to recover information
in the conversation and exploit it in
our solution is a point which is very
important is that  we come to
personalize our solution in relation
to a customer case if you are a bank
and a user calls and wants to
oppose his credit card
what is important for you opposition
and credit card and you
wanted these two words  keys generates
an important priority on this
conversation
so that's exactly what we do we
just add vocabulary which is
contextualized in relation to the cases in
the google machine learning solution
and we use the haye ears which
are available directly without
necessarily have to create our own
tool to chew their words what does
it solve in the end 1
it allows us to move from a model where we
use little data to a model
where we  exploits all the data en masse 2
it allows customers to come and
report on this data and
reinject it into their business tools and 3
it allows
an operator to make suggestions who will ultimately improve
their relationship with their customer if they  the
room is yours and yes in fact it was
n't over so we continue
you remember the example we
took at the beginning on the classification on
the images
globally the young people in hitiaa and that
's it  from an image you
return a whole bunch of metadata
on this image the functionalities
that we have in the young go pia and
it will be the detection of the beautiful so
the labeling of your images it will be the
detection of faces  so recognize
all the faces on an image but
also the position of the eyes mouth
the overall feeling of the face is what is
wearing a hat or not it's going to be
ocr features so
character extraction on an image
features  detection of
explicit content so games of content
considered adult or
violent content it will be
position detection so known places and
sending us back the location
latitude longitude and it will also
be logo detection so first
example photos that  doesn't
really highlight us it's the integration
our integration with google at the beginning
so we all wear our
noodle caps their with the little propellers
is generally on my face
he detects that I'm super happy
to be there he detects  also that I'm wearing
a hat
what's funny about this image is
that it also detects that my
colleague is wearing a hat and that he is
a little more dubious about being here and
wearing this propeller cap well I'm
not continuing  but again it
detects all the faces in the photo
eye placement
mouth placement and it also detects
categorization and safe labeling
on that photo
by the way we by identifying ourselves
as engineers thank you young people my
photo host is the best detection
is what you know where it is so it
looks like the eiffel tower in reality it
is not the eiffel tower it is  the bet
this hotel and casino of las vegas
I wanted to trap a little vis young people
who detected that it was about the
jump bet a casino of las vegas and who
therefore sent me the altitude and
longitude of this hotel  another
feature is the web rating
so here it is a photo of a ford
anglia which is taken from harry potter
2 so yes the rating will return to us
that it is an english ford it will return to us
that these present at the  rhein this
museum and that we can also see it in
harry potter it also returns
us other things
it will return us a list of urls where
the image fully matches a list
of urls or an image partially matches
and a list  of url that contains this
image in the page we still have
other other functions  nalities in this
dance is a country notably the ocr which
I was talking about earlier so
the extraction of two texts on an
image and the
sizing suggestion on an image
again this api so it is available
via api rest via  library clients
in most languages and you can u
e it this time on the slash of yo
ng people by the way for the example of ea
lier the f
urth photo overall he detec
ed therefore that it was a dog he has
pretty much pretty sure of the breed also
the last one he detected was a
mop and we're not going to do them all
but overall he needs to detect the
third one he had a doubt and he didn't
detect that  it was a dog but he
detected that it was a fur
I wouldn't have done better there
is just the 7th where he did not detect that
it was a mop but rather that
it was a  textile once again
beyond the dogs came out yesterday I will
hand over to  simon who presents a
concrete case thank you very much
no no the dogs the mops c1
it is recurrent with our customers
managing data in structured databases
everyone knows how to do it the challenge
today is to get the
data in the company which is unstructured
so it's the images it's the text and
we have a huge volume of data which
are present in the companies and which
we are not going to look for today
I will focus on
decade of use that we have with
clients who are more in banking
and insurance on unstructured data
that they receive and that they
must validate through workflows so
typically it is a request
to open an account c  it is
supporting documents that are sent these
contracts that are received and today
manually there are people who
will process these supporting documents
and who will validate them which can be
done very simply
it is by  example take an
identity card and send it to vision and
pay
google will give us the text
in the image and will also give us the
structure of the different elements
positioned in the image so that will
allow us  to replace this
manual process by an automatic validation
which will not only validate that
the data is indeed the user's data
but which will also verify
that the structure of a French identity card
which is always the same and
well preserved in  the case of a
supporting document
then afterwards we have slightly
more complex cases we have a client who wanted to
automatically classify contracts
a contract is a
fairly large structure we find different
pages of the clients present in the
contract and  just by using the
vision and pia clause and the nature
of the plunder angle we were able to
automatically classify contracts
based on the title of whether they
are sig  born or not the date of the contract
and then it's clips cases like
that I have plenty of them it can be
marketing products that are automatically classified
it can be an image that likes who
is a people at the start a user
on a  site and we want to check that it
has no explicit content
it can be to find flaws on a
production bench etc etc
what is important to remember is that
in this type of use case I
tell you  I'm talking to you today what we're
looking for is reliability
and efficiency, that is to say that we're going to
suggest that the business lines focus
more on their expertise and in
fact delegate to the algorithm their  tasks which are
redundant and which are low to
add if I need you thank you
so earlier we saw the analysis
on an image which is already quite
impressive now we
announce that we are also  able to
do it on video so from a
video sent a whole bunch of m  calibrated
on this video we will have in
main functionalities the detection
of the beauty so as we had on an
image we took out the labels present on
this image this time we will do it
at the level of the video by seeing the
labels and the times  associated attempts we will
also be able to do
face detection and follow the
face throughout this video to
detect changes should
even scene changes and to make a
suggestion for video segmentation we
will therefore immediately move on to  a little
demo that will make you think
for those who were present at that
of the cli note this morning or that
of earlier on this pitch globally
we take the videos we put them in a
file storage system which is
once again connected with a
function that will be triggered each time
new videos are added
this function will send to video
intelligence eyed pea and this time
and we will record  the result
so here it is so it's globally the
same interface
it's just that this time we have
videos on each on each video
I'm going to find the labels that are
associated well it's this one isn't
very it's not  very telling so I
'm going to move on to another video
so here you find below the
labels that are associated with this video for
example it has a lot of changes and
so I see all the labels with the
time stands what I'm able to
do is  now on a label
come and click and see the image that
corresponds and suddenly compared
to earlier where earlier we were doing
a search based on what was
said in the video
now we will also be able to do  a
search based on what we see in
the video so for example if we
search for all the videos where there is
a tower it will return this video to us
or in it we will have towers here is
the challenge it is globally  good for
demo  ion will return to the
presentation
so once again this api it
was stable api via library and
you can test it now on
your browser
this time with the smart drawn video slash
and and we are all going to move to
the latest api that  'we will talk
today about the country of translation
the apei of translation once again I
am quite confident with the fact that
you have already tested it all it
works on more than 110 languages
language detection  which is
done automatically
and what is strong enough is that it
is constantly improved a
fairly common new skies on translates airbnb
actually every time we
go to make a reservation on grass
the index in a travel context so
we are going to travel and what happens on
airbnb is that 50% of the reservations
we make are made in a language
that is not our mother tongue
in a country that does not speak the same
language as us  p with airbnb
finally what she likes to do
earlier is to use translate to
translate all the descriptions of the
places into
the user's native language as well as all the
associated comments associated with these
places I was telling you that  it was an
api that was constantly constantly
improved I think you must have
felt it in fact we made a
modification on our api where now
we have a neural network we have an
article which is very interesting which
talks about what  we did on it what
article on this link there if you want to
go and consult it later and
finally this api it is
constantly evolving
once again we can use it so
a free country and customers and you
can test it as soon as  now on your
browser
with the h 37 and I will now
immediately be invited to come on soul stage
so go yoann and david whom I thank
again for being there
hello I am in charge today
at solvay there is a team called
big data and ethics okay it is a
team which is both in charge of
technological solutions but which is
also a competence center which is there
to deliver projects at solvay
on  machine 2 machine learning and
ones and x in general so get up it's
a world leader in chemistry
so what's important in this
particular case is that we are
present all over the world
in 58 countries in  the world and that we
had one of 7000 employees within to get
up there is an entity called
shared services so the solvay
business services which supports
several of the major internal services
so we are talking about things like
invoices  orders payroll but
also all IT
we are talking here about hundreds of people
spread around the world including Serbs
in service centers but also
offshore partners in
particles for IT all these
services  ices there are called via a ticket
so when we want to use it service we have
to create a ticket so to
give you an idea of the order of magnitude today
we are at one hundred thousand tickets proce
sed per month okay so we  has
a huge database of 7 million
historical tickets so what is
also important is that today we have
tickets that come from 100
different countries because it comes from
customers and suppliers among others
and in 70 different languages
if we look at the current process
then first of all we have different
ticketing systems so our
users are a bit lost because
they don't know exactly
where they should go to create their
ticket and on top of that then there
the interface is a form where
the user is asked to categorize
these ccc tickets riddled with acronyms you can
imagine that our workers in china
have a lot of trouble knowing where
in the system they should create their ticket
so once we have taken this ticket,
we have entire teams
dedicated to translating these tickets
because we have partners who
only work in English, but also
the routes and is also changing the la la
prioritization so if we're just talking about
the translation part we have at least
1000 tickets to translate per month so
it takes 10 minutes per ticket we're
already 39 hours a day so obviously
nobody speaks 70 languages so that's a g
roup of people then  in
addition to all that so we process the ticket
but we also need to be
able to calculate capital to be
able to respect all the seals that
have been signed I will hand over to
yoann who will explain to you what is
we are now doing to improve
this situation
thank you our first challenge and therefore to
share with our
external collaborators who work exclusively
in English a certain amount
of information
the information is stored in
different ticket transactional systems
in consolidating a place
so we chose vicquery we
already saw earlier to consolidate
all the information when that of
the information in a single place was
not enough for us as I
said  we need to translate
so we used the 30 foot slate
to add the
translation information to each of our tickets you
can also see that there is the nlp which
is integrated why for the moment we
do not use  not but we know that the
structuring of textual information
is very important and in other
projects we have used it have
really realized the
added value of this type of tool
so we wanted to integrate it right
away  what results from these
tools put in place is firstly
a better analysis for ourselves
of the tickets what we now have a
dashboard which allows us to follow
all that we can see more easily the
life cycle of  each of the tickets from the
different systems and we can
collaborate with our partners in
English by having reduced the
workload on this side we do not at
all want to stop there it was a
start but the user for him c  'is
always complicated he always has to
choose between different tools
at present we want to go
further the first essential thing and
therefore to have a single interface which
can be a web application a chat
boots or both in which
the  user will simply come to
express his problem for example
happened to me he seems to be a very good
friend david he asked the question how to
get rid of my mother-in-law
we will have later how to
characterize this kind of  tickets there the
first thing to do quite simply
is to understand the will of the
person so there we feel that there is
something dishonest we could
even censor and
with other countries google
once q  we understood what
the user needed what
his problem
was we don't want to create a ticket
right away why add
workload right away when
we can return the user  much
more autonomous we will direct him
directly to the documentation at
that time the user will
answer his problem himself or not in the
event that he does not answer he will be able to
simply confirm that his
problem is still in  course and so
we are going to use what he expressed in
natural language to
automatically create the ticket when we create
the ticket we are going to add a lot
of information thanks to machine
learning the first thing is therefore
the different categories
obviously the  first to bellmer this
problems and there is therefore we also have the
translation on the fly with this time
prebuilt models but we can also
go further when we are a
user that we express a problem we
like b  know if we will see the
answer tomorrow after tomorrow or in a
month so we will also predict the date of
resolution of the ticket and we will
obviously prioritize it
also according to the dates so we end up with
a set of functionalities to
make the  user a little happier
this time we actually use
as the uci presented
earlier pre-built burning skies machines
so we still use a number
don't have yet also further
using tencer blur and claude  nachega
cloud emails in jeans to
simply deploy the model that we are
going to build on gc pays by doing
this we have a user experience which
will certainly improve and
above all we currently have a
performance which is sufficient
if we take  simply the two levels
of ticket categorization with what
we have done so far we
are already at more than 99% of correct
ticket classification which is
very interesting
small point in terms of project we may
have the impression that these are
long projects but you could see it
with the conferences before these are
projects that are quite quick to
set up with new technologies
here this  which was the longest it's
almost the definition of the cases then to
share after the development with the
api and the consolidation of a victory and
it was very fast a few months and the
end of the year here now we will
devote ourselves  to this version 2 that I
had to offer you in conclusion we have
here with the gcp tools these are
things that allow me to have
rapid development to reduce the
load in certain cases such as with the
translation
to have different services can
have them  a translation of the quality of
google betrayed by you good luck
and above all we can improve
the user experience
here we develop things for our
user and that is the important thing
our users  urs are satisfied with
what we have done and overall they
are happy to find a dashboard
that allows them to understand what
happened to analyze a little more the
past and the life cycles of tickets
now they are also very envious
and much much much more
demanding on the future, we give them
forecasts but they are
very confident and it is thanks in particular
to a collaboration with devoteam who
have made progress on this project that we have been able to
achieve this so I will leave it to them  the
hand to finish this beautiful conference
[Applause]
its amount thank you to n 6 is good thank you
the raid thank you david for this testimony
so machine learning
everyone talks about it but who is
it really two weeks ago I had
meeting with the IT department of a
French transport company and
machine learning topics came up in the
conversation since they make sense
in the company he is solving a
problem  number of
issues but at the end of the
conversation
the dsi told me simon machine learning
is great but not this year
this year I have to focus on
my PR this year I have to renew
my intranet and I ask myself a lot  of
questions about a machine learning project
which data is
eligible for a machine
learning project I have a monstrous volume of
data in my company
and especially when and how
can I get help  value
quickly good I had three good
news for this from the first
good news
already that's what we see is that it's
the business that appropriates a
machine learning project
why because its impacts so much  for
his daily life and the job is
very involved whether it is in time
since it is necessary to come and define the rules
of this ording thing and validate that the
solution is in place and that it
is also in a way to finance the second  xth
good news
the sexy we use google api a
machine learning project
it's simple and it's fast it's
simple because we come to consume
google's machine learning we don't come
to reinvent it ourselves and it's  fast
and good because the country it
gives us a record response time and the
third news sir the dsi
is good is that you can count
on devoteam for business this
project a success but devoteam who knows
devoteam
it  is a company of 5,000
employees
in Europe which has been serving
technology for a little over 20 years
so we work with major
accounts and we chose google as
nerve strata as a non-
strategic partner to develop the
transformation of the business and  the ds
devoteam g cloud or g cloud is the
google expertise within the group
we are passionate about google we are
led with google and we grew up with
google club and the three key figures
of g cloud it's 8 years of experience
it's 80 collaborators and its 1200
customers that we approached with us in
the google story me it's been six years
that I've been there and what makes
today that my  profession it is
always exciting is that I am
convinced that google will not
stop innovating and that I am going to say that you will
continue to offer methods to my
clients for challengers in their
daily lives and in their market  and our
conviction one way today it
is necessary to open communication
between the trades and we must
break down the silos of giving it to
multiply its value this conviction
I hope we have been able to show it to you
today  today
but if there is a message that I would
like you to remember from this
session it is this one a
machine learning project
it's simple it's powerful and it's
fast thank you very much
there you go thank you all  three and then
thank you all